first want to do this question would you
rather let your wife you once with
a strap on or take her last name when
you get married
hear me out bro
I'm gonna start off this answer by
saying No but
she me all right one time you
don't have to tell anybody but if you
take her last name you get every day bro
every time you put it we got a to-go
order for Trevor uh Carlson Wallace you
don't have to say the full part Trevor
Carlson Wallace caramel macchiato I said
Trevor um yeah you're doing one you just
taking the ones everybody did know
oh if everybody did know all right last
name it is bro but I'm married a girl
that has the same last name as me so it
sounds like I got a stutter and I'm like
oh yeah I'm Trevor Wallace Wallace so
like is he mentally right in the head